rbg uh passing that was
a real loss and i re i can't i mean
i you're a good person to ask because
they're like they're gonna bring the
vote up but then
republican senator two of them say
they're not gonna do it i don't
know i am not educated enough on
the system for right now before
just 50 days before an election whether
that could
actually it could could it actually
happen could they actually approve
someone
they also do have until the new
president is sworn in technically so
there's something called the lame duck
session which is between november 3rd
of this year and let's call it january
20th of next year so it's another
uh you know a couple months and change
um so the the rules are that they need a
majority vote to confirm
a new justice uh right now they have
53 republican senators and like you said
two said they don't want to do it
so now you you you have if you have one
more person let's call them mitt romney
who decides not to then you'd be at 50
50 but technically the vice president
can give a tie-breaking vote
in the senate so you need two more
republican senators to join the
this is not a good idea given this late
stage
caucus if you will and we're all waiting
to see whether there are two more
senators that
that head in that direction uh there's
nothing technically stopping them from
trying to do this before the end of the
year
for me it's crazy that we're dealing
with
the repercussions that are so
predictable of
uh like of just this antiquated way of
administering the supreme court
like that the fact that and i used to
say this on the trail joel i was like
like does it make sense that we are all
literally just waiting on tenterhooks
based upon the health of an 87 year old
woman uh
and you know and then she passes which i
hate to say it was like
somewhat predictable given that you know
she's been struggling with cancer for
years and years yeah that we needed to
have in my mind like a much more modern
approach to the supreme court for a long
time
uh and i i proposed 18-year term limits
when i was running which would
improve things dramatically because then
you know you get an appointment
the person's there for 18 years which is
a plenty long time in just about any
context
but they're not going to be there until
the day they die you don't have
uh this political firestorm coming up
out of nowhere when someone expires
the other big thing is you shouldn't
have only nine justices
you know which is another reason why
it's such a firestorm whenever
someone passes because each vote is so
pivotal
someone recommended 27 which struck me
as perfectly fine and
you just appoint a new one every two
years until you get up to that level
and then you have enough of a critical
mass you also don't need all 27 to hear
a case that's the other thing
is that in district courts some subset
of the judges will hear it
and then if it's a major ruling that
overturns a precedent then they can
bring everyone in
um so that it's it's just painful to see
our country struggling with something
based upon a law
that was passed in 1869 and there was an
1869 law that said
nine justices but all you need them is a
is a majority vote to say
you know what it's not gonna be nine
anymore like and then uh you can change
it because there's nothing in the
constitution about nine so
i'm all excited about the fact that we
need to try and modernize our government
that's one of my new jams joel
modernize the government yes and the
supreme and the supreme court
has the most archaic approach you can
think of it's like
it really is like something out of a uh
game of thrones or some science fiction
novel it's like we have these nine
unelected folks that we appoint and
they're there until the day they die
and you're like checking their blood
pressure and whatnot to see like oh are
you gonna be here for for
30 or 40 years so that like so nothing
could change during that time the whole
thing
uh is just mind-blowingly
out of date i agree you know
and you've framed that perfectly because
it is you forget that when
like when scalia died it was just like
this huge surprise
and and then there's this huge you know
like as you said it's like this gigantic
reaction because they're appointed for
life
and yeah if it was 18 years which is a
good run at any job
that would you would know and it would
be
way easier i mean there's so many things
it's so
strange to think i learned it mostly
from hamilton but
uh i read the book too but uh you're
like oh they just
put these things tons of it works really
well
but there is room for improvement to
say the least my lord that that's the
unofficial motto of america now
unfortunately when it comes to
government joel it's like america
don't change anything you know it's like
like america
fixed in stone we had this rule and it
was delivered to us on a tablet
uh no it wasn't i mean these guys
brilliant brilliant
uh people put together a system but the
system needs to
adapt and evolve uh and dc is not really
built for evolution that way
that to me is something that should be
non-partisan or bipartisan it's like
look
let's just modernize and you can imagine
a more modern approach to supreme court
terms and and appointments
you can imagine a more modern approach
to legislation
and voting yeah voting
for sure i mean the the fact that we're
we're dealing with some of like the
fears we're dealing with around voting
uh and i'm not someone like i understand
the technology and understand that look
if you just had um all of our voting
done via smartphone first there's a
there's a major party that actually
likes to have people not vote which you
know that so that that's one
set of issues um but it is true that
some of the technology
would not be ready for prime time but
you have to start moving in that
direction and there could be a period
when you have
you have more advanced voting via
smartphone and then you
have some paper redundancy for a while
or whatnot you know and you can like use
things as backup
uh like that there are different
approaches you could take that it's not
just
all uh in one direction and americans
would love that stuff
if if we were like if we're like look
you're gonna vote the old-fashioned way
it's cool
but we're gonna do this pilot program of
of digital voting too and we're just
gonna like start
stress testing it and see how it works
and see how you like it and whatnot like
that that would be
awesome i know like that that would be
an intelligent approach
instead uh a lot of it is political
where a lot of folks
like things the way they are for um
really just for keeping things the same
right now the congressional approval
rating
around the country is 21 percent which
is very low
and it's about um even with what it's
been this last number of years it's even
been lower at times been like 17.
the re-election rate for members of
congress
is 94 so think about that for a second
you're like wait a minute none of us are
happy with what's going on but
like everyone wins let's come back and
be like well if i want to keep my seat
i win and there are a bunch of
structural reasons for that
i mean part of it's gerrymandering and
the way the districts are set up
part of it though is just this massive
fundraising advantage
where the average successful house
candidate raised 1.6 million
for senate it's 10.4 million and so
can you imagine a normal person trying
to raise 1.6 million for a congressional
campaign
be impossible it's like you know like
like i mean i was frankly something of
an unknown
um but i remember raising that first set
of money and it was brutal
like no one wanted to give i give
anybody either i was like hey
you and i have been friends for a long
time i'm running for president you want
to donate 20
uh 700 in my campaign and that that
stuff was really really difficult so
for anyone who is trying to do the right
thing and
you know run for congress for their
district like unless you've been
cultivating tons of relationships with
people that have money over a period of
time like you're not going to be able to
raise another to be competitive
and frankly if you were the sort of
person that was cultivating those
relationships for a long time
you probably are not the person where
hoping runs
like those two things are kind of
mutually yeah they have no choice but to
cultivate those relationships
because they're not going to raise the
money if they don't and it's so
you know like camp the campaigning is
endless it starts
so it's it makes you know like
buying it's like buying christmas gifts
in july
and i like the uh european i guess it's
british where they're like okay you can
come
start campaigning on this day and then
yes for it and then it stops
and and but the system is
so ingrained and it help you know it's
helped a lot of
people and so they're not gonna stop it
the never-ending campaign man i just saw
this stat that said um
like barack obama in his last year in
office when he
like uh or one of the years he was
running for re-election it might have
been 2012.
attended over 200 fundraisers that year
and and you're just like how are you
trying to run the country right
and show up to 200 fundraisers does
anyone think that's like an optimal use
of this
or freaking trump has never stopped
campaigning and then you think about the
senate and then you think about congress
and
obviously the state congress all of that
and they're all doing it
and i just like i don't know what if you
were
would you want your doctor uh if your
doctor had to raise their salary
you know like no no i want them to focus
on medicine
and making sure that i stay healthy and
they're up to date with the latest
information and not
out doing this work to you know just
maintain them
themselves thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode